JACK ROONEY: TV producing
workflows are very complex
and they're layered.
And it requires an integration
with backend broadcast systems
that can deliver content
to our digital platform.
Anvato provides that
integration as well as
provides on-prem coding
software and hardware for both
live and VOD.
With their SAS
platform, it enables
us to do video
management and video
delivery to multiple endpoints,
including mobile as well
as our web VR content
management systems.
MARK BECK: Cox Media Group
is an integrated broadcast,
publishing, direct marketing,
and digital media company.
The core of our business
is television, radio,
and newspaper.
So the Anvato platform
really allowed
us to design a simpler
and much more flexible
video architecture.
And it really helped to
take the friction out
of integrating between
our broadcast publishing
video plants, our CMS,
and the video platform.
BALA SUNDARAMOORTHY: When
we looked at audience trend,
audience is moving from
traditional broadcast
television watching to
watching videos on the web,
on their desktop, to
watching on laptops,
to watching on their
mobile devices.
One of our key goals is to
be where our audience is.
So when we wanted to
try to solve that,
we were looking
for a platform that
allows us to
seamlessly be available
where our audience is.
Anvato provides a great
platform and an API
that allows us to have the
same player across of all
of these different
delivery content platforms.
And when we looked at the kind
of content we want to provide,
we want to make
both our live video
content and video on
demand be available
on all these platforms.
And that's what we were able to
achieve with Anvato platform.
JACK ROONEY: Video to TV station
source from multiple points.
You could have end-user
submitted video from the field,
you have camera
folks and reporters
that are out in the field
covering news events.
As well as live coverage that
are coming from the broadcast
systems.
So all of that is key input
into the Anvato platform
that allows those TV
producers to cut and edit
as they see fit.
And then provide that content
out to the content management
systems.
BALA SUNDARAMOORTHY:
What we are looking
for in our video solution
is full integrated
end-to-end solution
for video, right?
It was key' for us
that the solution
have a very tight integration to
a broadcast production system,
like Avid.
It was important to us that it
has robust input capabilities
and ability to get files
through FTP, MRSS, you name it,
we needed that.
On the other end
of the scale, we
needed strong output mechanisms,
rollbase syndication and things
like.
The SAS platform was a
perfect niche fit for us
from that standpoint.
JACK ROONEY: We've rolled the
Anvato platforms to our 10 TV
stations with great success.
We've also integrated with our
Nielsen measurement platform.
We are about to bring
on our radio stations
in the very near future.
So, if you combine that
with all of the things
that we've done from a
measurement perspective,
both on Nielsen and other
measurement platforms,
Anvato has been a great partner.
And we've had very
good success to date.
[MUSIC PLAYING]